parce que c'est cool pour moi c'est la
taille des doigts dans le nez chez check
ça s'est terminé
ces trois-là 20h16 qu'est ce que vous
pensez transports en commun parisiens
ben on est on est vachement serré en
fait dans les métros après ça dépend la
ligne comprend mais moi je prends
souvent l'a13 et du coup bah ouais
beaucoup de beaucoup de pros proximité
avec autrui quoi et votre charge
bon je crois acer va aller dans le sud à
la pas ce problème là elle prend pas le
mail étrange passé une tête
salut ça va ça va bien et toi ça va se
faire je remercie ouais pareil je prends
pas ça va je suis du sud au jeu seront
un peu moins de transports parisiens
quoi bon on vous laisse certes ouailles
un peu froide mais on est contentes
sûrement se seraient mises one piece by
elle est fan qu'est ce que vous pensez
des transports en commun parisiens à
grand chose je les sens très utile mais
si je peux longuement dispensés jeunes
en dispense et votre chat on pense quoi
ma soeur c'est juste ça va la soeur
jumelle ouais on a on et jumelles on a
deux ans d'écart il est juste un peu
plus poilu qu'est ce que vous pensez des
transports en commun parisiens entendent
maintenant ça pourrait être mieux pour
beaucoup trop de monde
ces pratiques disons quoi est votre rêve
elle en pense quoi
puis st votre heure j'en ai pas
il va accoucher l'an passé à 8,6 du raja
pas billet philo chez moi c'est par un
bombe à aller à la prochaine bêta
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]